هذا ما تبقى من المركبه التي كان يستقلها
الشهيدان عز الدين حمامره وامجد خليليه في
نهايه ملاحقه قوات الاحتلال لهم في بلده
جبع جنوبيه جنين الجيش الاسرائيلي قال ان
احدى دورياته تعرضت لاطلاق نار من سياره
مسرعه قرب مدخل البلده فطاردتها واطلقت
النار على من بداخلها
من الحزن خيمت على اهالي الشهداء خاصه
والفلسطينيين عامه في جنين شهود وعيان
اكدوا ان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعدم من كانوا
بداخل السياره بعد توقفها
السياره لمكملت شوي اييه اجوا جيش حاوطوا
السيارات ونزلوا من الجيبات وصفوهم يعني
بكل بالسياره اعدام يعني اعدموهم اعدام
[تصفيق]
وفي موكب التشييع تعالت الهتافات المطالبه
بالثار لحمام وخليليه الى جانب يزن
الجعبري الذي استشهد متاثرا بجروح اصيب
بها مطلع الشهر الجاري
حركه الجهاد التي ينتمي اليها الشهيدان
دعت الى تعزيز الوحده الوطنيه في مواجهه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نستطيع مواجهه هذا العدو بمزيد من الصبر
والثبات ومزيد من تعزيز الوحده الوطنيه
على الارض والميدان على اساس البندقيه نحن
مختلفون سياسيين ولكن نحن كل شعبنا وكواهم
متفقين على خيار الشهداء والجرح والاسرى
وقد عم الاضراب العام مدينه جنين حدادا
على ارواح الشهداء ففي مختلف انحاء الضفه
الغربيه استشهد عدد من الفلسطينيين منذ
بدايه هذا العام كان نصيب محافظه جنين
وحدها سبعه شهداء كما لم يستمر الاطفال من
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال للمدن والبلدات الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه يقول الفلسطينيون ان عمليات
الاغتيال الاسرائيليه والتي كان اخرها
اغتيال حمام رواد خليليه في جنين ستواصل
طالما استمرت عمليات الاقتحام والمداهماته
لمدونهم وقراهم خاصه ان هذه العمليه جاءت
عاقبه تسلم حكومه فديه جديده بمقاليد
الحكم حكومه توصف بانها الاكثر تصرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل
سمير ابو شماله الجزيره جنين فلسطين